I finally did it did you read what a
Super Bowl what a fun easy sport I'm
telling you all this has happened before
okay time for that Darkness Retreat we
are stuck in a script of a show that
just keeps repeating itself and its name
is
I wish I could see things clearly try
this it's a little untraditional say no
more well guess I'll go down the Jets
with my Wrangler jeans whoa some drink
what's he smoking huh expired Gatorade
from when I was in St Louis back to work
JK maybe this here I'll go back to work
LOL is it always like this B.o.B will
you be my OC whoa can't wait to
definitely play football this year
Stefan Diggs is disgruntled finally one
of my conspiracy theories is true
welcome remember to dress up as your
three using scripts we already did a
whole Brady thing oh yeah we're not
trapped next year will be the bills here
next year will be the bills here next
year will be the bills here next year
will be the bills year next year will be
the bills year next year will be the
bills here oh my gosh he's right wait
where's Aaron people woke up looking for
me if I missed McAfee whoa Secret door
Aaron I'm so sorry I left you I don't
know it wasn't your fault
your scripts
Saint joins the Chiefs okay don't hate
that one oh
yeah I decide which story lines are epic
enough to happen but free will why are
you repeating everything oh geez
spectacular
fire Emoji destroy the next hundred
years of football scripts choose chaos
that is if you think that's what people
really want you script writers time out
I like the routine I underperform one
year I over form the next I get paid
repeat but Kirk don't you want to win
I'm not sure I can do you know why I'm
so confident the cigar because you're
really good because you're super hot
because when the abyss stares at me I
stare at the back Kirk I believe a lot
of wacky things but I have to believe
any of us even you could win
through 100.
[Music]
all right time to approve next year's
Scripts
one where are the scripts the Devonte
and Aaron need to get back together the
clammy was supposed to come back in a
big way we were finally gonna do an
Avengers End Game parody every episode
was gonna go so Vine roll
oh the unknown Anything could happen oh
God what if the lions are good
foreign